HIMSELF.
>> HE MADE EVERYBODY FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE BECAUSE THEY WERE
EXHAUSTED.
>> Jason: I LIKED WHAT RAND
PAUL HAD TO SAY.
HERE TO DISCUSS THE ISSUE IS
SEAN DUFFY OF WISCONSIN WHO
VOTED FOR THE BILL AND RADIO
TALK SHOW HOST GARLAND NIXON.
CONGRESSMAN DUFFY, I WAS ABLE
TO SERVE WITH YOU, AN HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO DO SO AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TONIGHT.
YOU VOTED FOR THE BILL.
THERE IS A COMPELLING REASON
YOU DID THAT.
WHY DID YOU VOTE FOR THE BILL?
>> LICENSE, WE’RE IN A
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE A
DILAPIDATED MILITARY.
PLANES THAT CAN’T FLY.
WE GIVE OUR MILITARY A MISSION
TO ACCOMPLISH BUT NOT THE
RESOURCES TO ACCOMPLISH THE
MISSION.
THE SEQUESTER HAS CRUSHED OUR
ABILITY TO DEFEND OURSELVES.
WE HAVE THREATS OF CHINA, NORTH
KOREA, IRAN.
WE PASSED A BILL OUT OF THE
HOUSE THAT WAS CONSERVATIVE.
I SUPPORTED THE BILL.
AS YOU KNOW ALL TOO WELL AND
YOUR LISTENERS HEAR THIS QUITE
A BIT.
WHEN OUR BILL WENT TO THE
SENATE.
YOU CAN’T PASS IT WITH JUST
REPUBLICAN VOTES.
SCHUMER EXTRACTED ADDITIONAL
SPENDING.
WE HAD A CHOICE IN THE HOUSE.
DO WE TAKE THE DEAL THAT CHUCK
SCHUMER THREW MORE SPENDING
INTO WHICH GETS OUR MILITARY
BACK ON TRACK TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS THAT WE HAVE IN THE
WORLD, OR DO WE SAY NO AND KEEP
THESE REALLY HORRIBLE BUDGET
CAPS ON THE MILITARY THAT DON’T
LET THEM ACCOMPLISH THEIR
MISSION.
FOR ME I DON’T LIKE THE
SPENDING IN THE BILL BUT I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE OUR MILITARY
MEN AND WOMEN CAN DEFEND US AND
ACCOMPLISH THE MISSION WE GIVE
THEM.
>> Jason: GARLAND, IF YOU WERE
IN CONGRESS HOW WOULD YOU YOU
HAVE VOTED?
WOULD YOU HAVE VOTED AGAINST IT?
>> I WOULD HAVE BEEN PUSHING TO
HOLD OUT FOR DACA FROM THE LEFT
SIDE.
BUT MY FEELING IS THIS, I THINK
THAT -- MY OPINION I THINK
THERE ARE SOME REDUCTIONS WE
COULD DO IN THE MILITARY AND WE
COULD HAVE DONE THAT BY
BRINGING TROOPS HOME FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
BUT ADDITIONALLY I THINK IT’S
DISINGENUOUS TO SAY YOU CAME UP
WITH THE BILL AND SHOCKED TO
FIND OUT THERE WAS ANOTHER
PARTY IN CONGRESS THAT YOU WERE
GOING TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
I DON’T REMEMBER IN MY LIFETIME
WHEN ONE PARTY HAD SUPER
MAJORITIES IN BOTH HOUSES AND
THE WHITE HOUSE AND DIDN’T HAVE
TO BARGAIN FOR SOMETHING.
>> Jason: THINK BACK IN 2009
AND 2010 IN OBAMACARE.
A SUPER MAJORITY IN THE SENATE
AND SHOVED DODD-FRANK AND
OBAMACARE DOWN OUR THROATS.
>> Jason: WHY DIDN’T THE
DEMOCRATS UNANIMOUSLY VOTE FOR
THIS?
NOTHING WAS CUT OF ANY
SUBSTANCE AND IT SUPPORTED OUR
MILITARY, SOMETHING I THOUGHT
DEMOCRATS WERE SUPPORTIVE OF.
AND I UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO DO
DACA.
I DON’T THINK YOU GO ANY
FURTHER THAN WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP, SPEAKER RYAN AND MITCH
MCCONNELL HAVE DONE SAYING WE
FLED TO ADDRESS IT.
BY THE WAY, BARACK OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT FOR EIGHT YEARS AND
NEVER ADDRESSED THE IMMIGRATION
ISSUE.
>> I WISH THEY WOULD HAVE
ADDRESSED IT WHEN THEY HAD THE
MAJORITIES OF THE HOUSE AND
THEY DIDN’T.
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE NOW.
NOW THE PEOPLE THAT DIDN’T GO
FOR IT, THE DEMOCRATS DON’T
HAVE LEVERAGE OR DACA.
THEY THREW THAT OUT AND MAY NOT
GET ANYTHING.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS THAT HELD
OUT WASN’T BECAUSE OF THE
BUDGET.
IT WAS FOR OTHER REASONS.
>> WE CAN’T FALL INTO THE TRAP
OF THINKING THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SUPPORTING THE MILITARY.
THEY’VE BEEN USING THE MILITARY
AS LEVERAGE TO GET OTHER
SPENDING.
WE COULD HAVE ADDRESSED THIS
ISSUE MONTHS AGO AND GIVEN THE
MILITARY THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO ACCOMPLISH THE MISSION.
TO COME ON HERE AND SAY THEY
ACTUALLY ARE SUPPORTERS OF THE
MILITARY, THEY HAVEN’T BEEN.
THERE WAS -- THEY WANT TO SEE
MILITARY SPENDING DEPLETED AND
THEY WANT US TO PULL OUT OF
VERY ROUGH REGIONS OF THE WORLD
IRAQ OR AFGHANISTAN.
WE SAW HOW WELL IT WORKED.
IT WAS THE RISE OF ISIS WHEN
BARACK OBAMA PULLED OUT AND
LEFT A VACUUM AND YOU HAD
PEOPLE BURNING THEIR ENEMIES
AND BEHEADING PEOPLE.
WE HAVE TO BE SMART ABOUT OUR
POLLZ. CUTTING THE MILITARY IS
NOT SMART POLICY WITH THE
RISING THREATS IN THE WORLD.
>> Jason: HOW DO YOU ANSWER THE
QUESTION THAT RAND PAUL WAS OUT
THERE SAYING LOOK, REPUBLICANS
WERE OPPOSED TO THESE DEFICITS
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS IN
PLACE.
NOW THAT THEY’RE DONALD TRUMP
WE SEEM TO BE OKAY WITH A
TRILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT NEXT
YEAR.
>> FIRST OF ALL YOU USE GROWTH
NUMBERS THAT ARE OBAMA GROWTH
NUMBERS AND YOU USE TRUMP
GROWTH NUMBERS THOSE DEFICITS
WON’T BE THAT BIG.
AGAIN, THAT’S THE PROBLEM WHEN
CHUCK SCHUMER IS A BIG SPENDER
AND LEVERAGING THE MILITARY FOR
ADDITIONAL SPENDING IN
NON-MILITARY DISCRETIONARY
SPENDING.
THAT’S THE DEAL THAT HAD TO BE
MADE.
AGAIN, FOR ME THIS IS A TOUGH
VOTE BUT I SIDE I HAD WITH THE
MILITARY.
THAT’S THE MOST IMMEDIATE
THREAT.
ONE LAST POINT.
IF WE WANT TO DEAL WITH THAT
YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH
ENTITLEMENTS.
THEY’RE THE KEY TO REDUCING THE
MASSIVE OUTFLOW IN THE
GOVERNMENT.
UNTIL YOU GET TO THAT YOU WON’T
ADDRESS THE MASSIVE DEFICIT AND
DEBTS.
>> Jason: THANK YOU, I’LL GIVE
YOU THE LAST WORD, PAUL RYAN
THE SPEAKER SAID HE WANTS TO
ADDRESS THE ENTITLEMENT REFORM.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU OR
THE DEMOCRATS THINK COULD GET
BEHIND AND SUPPORT?
>> I HOPE NOT.
I FEEL AS THOUGH --
>> Jason: THERE IS THE PROBLEM
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THAT’S